here's a guy who's probably going to get
accused of a hate crime at some point
he's in a truck oh i like him
brendan theo king of the same crew this
is mark coming at you from that work
truck
i got a name game for you sandwiches
the name of the game is sammy's baby i'm
talking hot sandwiches
old sandwiches oh yeah room temperature
sandwich oh yeah ice cream
sandwich will do any meat between
two pieces of bread that's what i call a
sammy baby
so hit it up heavy with them sandwiches
what's going on it's like thompson girl
down with the thickness pop us down 20
pounds get some gang gang
buzz buzz
bro i can't believe that guy took the
panty off his head and quit sending it
and got a new job
and r.i.p to that guy he passed away
we've been trying to get in touch with
him for months haven't we
what was his name j-rod
now he's driving long-haul but i respect
that man look brother thank you for
being out there there's nothing braver
than driving along all you out there 14
gears bro
not knowing which one was 14 years yeah
mountains and steep mountains and [ __ ]
because they had crossed off you were
nine
and you went eleven brought in you in
two dude that's right my grandpa my
uncles
that's a lifelong truck driver so nice
to go with them yeah that's at arm math
baby you got to do it right
eating [ __ ] food all the time all
those stop those coming goes
yeah hot lizards knocked on your door
they get to sleep there right
yeah there's a uh have you seen the
documentary a lot of the documentary
no have you not seen that what
it's about lot lizards yeah what on hbo
dark or some [ __ ] yeah you don't even
research your own life dude
yeah it's on the netflix whoa
here's somebody right here a seancer i
thought i made up the term lot lizard
i'm a tomboy
at heart oh he's having a trailer for a
lot lizards oh my god
i think it helps me to make more money
helps me more look look more girly
this is on the phone she looks like otis
nixon a little bit you can play for the
braves i will say when i'm doing
my hustle
and dealing with truck drivers it is
what it is
well yeah man it's a tough racket
it is i think why because
because i've never been on my own
that's the truck driver there i can't
call that [ __ ] no no that's her
husband
that is not me apparently she lost her
ass too
is it brendan sorry
that's her husband people put too much
emphasis
on things that you can see
half of what you see isn't really what
you're saying it's
i don't know what you're talking about
someone there's a lot lizards
does she do palm readings too or what's
going on here
the fact that brendan thought he made up
lot lizard absolutely blows
i like it man i yeah we should have
never told you
i mean that trailer looks [ __ ]
terrible but the trailer is not a good
trailer
no that was awful yeah you could get
something much better producer over at
draft
drastic graphics with martial she was
like what you see
isn't really what you get with lights
yeah man is she a motivational speaker
she's a notivational speaker but so this
guy's talking about sandwiches he won't
just have a contest doesn't he nick
yeah name game oh i name the sandwiches
okay oh [ __ ] hey what's up
okay damn yeah maybe take it easy
florida georgia live come on dog
i just got excited and there's otis
nixon's reference dog
she looked a little like otis nixon a
lot
god bless just sandwiches period like
cold cuts or any sandwiches he said hot
sandwiches cold sandwiches
hot coffee cool coffee
hot coffee cool coffee go ahead you
little lizard i call cold coffee
i don't know what they call a polar bear
coffee go ahead lot lizard
um i'm gonna start off in honor
of our boy mumbling mun the
medium i'm going to drop this freaking
yum puff on you
the bond me yeah there you go
shout out dude jesus christ or you call
it
the bond mine i'm sure when you see it
i don't know what you're talking about
uh let's go with that peanut butter and
jelly hitter my favorite
oh extra on the butter you feel me that
basic [ __ ]
thought nugget there's nothing more
american than a peanut butter jelly
sandwich you [ __ ] delinquent
not surprised you chose that dude what's
yours um i'm gonna go
with a sandwich that a lot of people
enjoy i'm going to go with something
that
i would something seem like probably a
delicacy to nick
the grilled cheese
my grandma would put him at george
foreman grills
[Applause]
dude i will say this dude my mom used to
grill uh peanut butter
and jellies and those were good bro
i never heard of them you ever had that
nick oh yeah on the george foreman
oh wow oh yeah everything went on the
george foreign must have been rich
dude i'll tell you what i used to do on
the former two a little thing about my
hawaiian friends while i'm talking about
that
spam sandwich dog little mustard spam
what's up cat it's good that's your
medium about that [ __ ]
okay dude what's up all right bro i've
had enough of this [ __ ] conversation
dude because i'm gonna go with that
muffalatta baby
bring it up nick what is that bring up
that freaking dirty muffalatta bro
that hard bro no you're talking about
that hard hit you keep making
pseudonic
god damn you rich son well no y'all need
to quit eating
inside of gas stations and [ __ ] live
a little i'll tell you my favorite
sandwich is that roast beef
hit or dug with a nice sharp cheddar
a roast beef sandwich that sharp cheddar
don't even start naming cheeses again
i already won that one i won that one i
lost on pies though
yeah bro you've lost on a lot dude bro
i'm not even playing games with y'all's
fake ass bruh
one thing i'll say right now is dude i'm
gonna go with that
fried oyster poor boy dog straight out
of louisiana bring up that picture
nicholas
boom mf put that in your fat cheeks bruh
put that in your fat bike riding ass
bruh you know what i'm saying get out of
there
dude i'll ride a couple miles for that
that
had a nice ass lobster roll son bring up
that [ __ ] lobster roll
oh he's going off shore yeah dog i'm
taking to them spiders of the sea
dude hugs as they call it he going
offshore
baby favorite and dude they got cousins
maine lobster sandwiches here it's a
food truck
bro bro twenty four dollars a pop is
that how much it is twenty four dollars
a pop
food truck i'll say this bro i i thought
they were impressive
until i saw them in another city and
that's when i realized are they in maine
though
it would no it wasn't maine same truck
same place
yeah dude worldwide mr worldwide nah oh
that's out here
oh is it ever it's my favorite food
truck all the food trucks that's numero
[ __ ] i like authentic bruh 24 bucks
so first
for i'm allergic to shellfish so i can't
eat this you can't have self shellfish
no
nothing no bugs megan makes the best
lobster rolls yeah
rather than homemade these things your
friend megan these things
ain't nobody believe in that
when's the last time a friend was like
okay i got lobster rolls
never the answer is never bro you're the
one who eats them out of a
truck yeah dog that's a legit truck
there not your friend
megan you're the one who come out of a
truck like some damn [ __ ]
lot lizard dude
i love them man okay my sandwich sure
all right i'll go with uh let me think
of a good sandwich for you
right now any sandwich we're gonna be
here all [ __ ] day
no we won't bro i know you
foster that's one of his defense tactics
dude that's
i think the lobster off he goes with the
oyster thing
i'm saying you were going to say it
again but but they get limited though we
can't do another lobster sandwich man no
you can't you know
so is that the rule you can't use
another meat twice bro if you want to
bust a nut in a theater nothing helps by
having a little bit of that
peter paul ruben in your mouth
i don't like rubens huh i don't like
rubens oh god
you like rubens yes that one looks nice
oh that one looks that one looks nice
the first one you see
actually enough cheese on it yeah
actually that looks really good you
don't like reuben's pick a sammy
well nothing makes my day better than
watching theo deep throw a six
incher of meatball subs
what's up bro take it to the dome that
meatballs sub
oh i love a nice meatball they are good
who thought of that what a great idea
he's getting flashbacks of jared's
sister
[Laughter]
take two inches off of that sub
okay i don't even think that five dollar
foot long
uh yeah i was humming that four inch
round around dude
my penis is shaped like a candy corn
do we call it a draw yeah we'll be here
all day
you can't have a whole episode of just
sandwiches yeah just my fat ass name in
sandwiches bro you know how many fat
guys are right now listening to this
loving us foaming out the mouth
yeah you know how many guys that
couldn't get tickets to bur crisis
drive-in tour right
[Laughter]
absolutely using this as their second
option dude let's get cats medium on and
get your friend megan in here to make
these lobster roll stuff
she makes good lobster rolls brandon i'm
not fine
dude
[Music]